very good evening consumers are facing a
bleak winter of higher fuel costs after
ScottishPower announced its increasing
gas prices by nineteen percent
electricity bills by ten percent and
that means an average customer of which
there are nearly two and a half million
will have to pay around an extra hundred
and seventy-five pounds a year all the
other big energy companies are expected
to follow suit tonight the warnings that
that could put half a million people
into fuel poverty his skies tie yet
right so far it's been a hot hot summer
but this winter energy firms are turning
up the heat ScottishPower is the first
of the big suppliers to reveal just how
much its customer prices will rise the
hike will see domestic gas bills
rocketing by an average of nineteen
percent from the first of August
electricity bills will increase by ten
percent ScottishPower says it will
affect 2.4 million households history
tends to show that a lot of companies
will follow the slipstream with the
first one to raise their prices so we
shouldn't be surprised to see two three
four of the others put not everyone that
would necessarily do it and the scale
now is set so we will be expecting to
see prices of a magnitude that we
weren't expecting before this
announcement the political crisis and
many parts of the Middle East has added
an average of thirty percent to the
costs for energy firms supplying
customers caught up in an economic
crisis Scottish powers explanation
wholesale prices for gas and electricity
have increased significantly since the
end of last year and continuing on rests
in global energy markets means future
prices are volatile Scottish Power says
it understands times are difficult for
many people and it's done what it can to
absorb these additional costs for as
long as possible to minimize the impact
on customers the Bank of England has
already warned households to prepare for
average energy price rises of fifteen
percent this year that's part of the
reason it expects inflation to his five
percent even if inflation does rise very
sharply over the course of the next few
months as a consequence
of rising energy costs as these one-off
Rises drop out of the calculations so
we'll see a sharp decline back in the
inflation rate in 12 months time the
energy regulator has already said it
doesn't think there's enough competition
in the market the big firms are given
until the start of this month to say how
they'll change their ways to keep prices
as low as possible if they don't go far
enough a full competition investigation
could be launched and that's something
the suppliers don't want to happen ty
God's Bernard awesome from London
studios evening tide for directa
surprise this and just perhaps the first
of many yeah I think we can't expect the
others to follow suit and yes there was
surprised that it was as high as this
and of course it sets the bar that's bit
higher for the others to follow and
course that adds to the woes of
consumers are already grappling with
high inflation and low wage growth the
big question is though is is it fair do
the prices really have to go up as much
as this and that of course is difficult
for us to say on the outside of energy
firms because they keep their books to
themselves and that's one of the things
that the energy regulator off Jem says
should change it once more transparency
and how the energy firms set their
prices back in March it launched a
pretty blistering attack on the sector
is saying that it was failing to play it
straight and stifling competition and it
made a number of recommendations as to
how they could change their ways they've
been given a chance to make their own
recommendations they've been that the
gauntlet has been thrown down to them to
encourage competition in the market they
had until earlier this week to give
their responses to off jen off Gemma's
looking at them now and will give their
own response next month if they're not
good enough though as we said a full
competition investigation could take
place and that could really shake things
up Jeremy thanks very much tied